méxico tiene una larga y orgullosa
historia de recibir a refugiados y
exiliados de hecho méxico recibió a
muchos de los judíos durante el
holocausto que canadá rechazo dio la
bienvenida a los exiliados del chile
bajo pinochet la guerra sucia en
argentina y en los años 90 y 80 recibió
a casi un millón de personas de
centroamérica
en teoría la política de dictaminar
refugiados de mexico de 2011 es más
generosa que la de canadá porque méxico
utiliza la definición más amplia de
refugiado que se encuentra en la
convención de cartagena la definición
incluye violencia realizada como causa
de la migración forzada el problema es
que ha sistema de determinación de
refugiados en méxico está sobrecargado y
con fondos insuficientes
canadá está en una posición muy
privilegiada porque está geográficamente
aislada
compartimos una frontera solo con los
eeuu y por eso en canadá puede
seleccionar la gente que quiere recibir
méxico por su parte es la puerta a
norteamérica al igual que españa es la
puerta a europa
esto significa que mucha gente van a
entrar a méxico
[Música]